David Golan, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute leaders.
Thanks for having me.
Well, artificial intelligence,
health care, helping save lives,
postdoc at Stanford,
this is a complete honor of mine.
So, I'm very very glad to have you.
David, you're the CTO of Viz.ai.
I can't believe you just tell
you're over a hundred people
across the US and Israel?
That's just insane.
David, right before we go back
to your personal journey,
give me a little bit of context
what is Viz.ai and how do you integrate
artificial intelligence with health care?
So, our mission at Viz.ai
is to facilitate better care for patients
by applying artificial intelligence,
detecting for example, stroke
or other pathologies that require
immediate attention and alerting
the right physician immediately
using our AI and using our own
mobile platform so they can treat
the patient much faster.
So, just for context about the problem,
you're saying this idea
of detecting a stroke.
When I think of somebody having a stroke,
I think about the movies;
I'm thinking about somebody who is
stopping in the middle of the street;
they're starting to realize
that something is weird;
they made me fall down
and then eventually,
somebody will call 911.
I'm guessing that the problem
is that oftentimes it's too late, right?
I mean, that every second there counts.
Yeah. So, stroke is
the single most time critical condition
in all of medicine, with the exception
of a kid choking on a grape.
Every minute that goes by,
the patient loses two million neurons
that translate to over four days
of disability free life.
So, it's really a race against time.
And we all have these images from media
of someone who is having a stroke
and being rushed to the hospital.
The sad fact is that the delays
typically happen
within the hospital system.
So, the largest delays are
after the patient is admitted,
actually, more often than not
even after the patient is imaged,
so the patient was in a city scanner
somewhere in a file system,
there's a sequence of bits and bytes
that tells this patient
is having a stroke,
but just the system it's human based,
very sequential linear system
is not efficient
at triaging those patients
identifying who needs
emergent care and who doesn't.
And sort of skipping the queue
and making sure the right patient
gets the right treatment.
And this is basically what we do.
Right. So, it's not a problem
of proficiency, of taking care of it,
but it's a problem of diagnosing
the urgency of the situation, right?
Exactly.
So, it's really not about,
in the context of AI and radiology
and interpreting scans,
people will sort of saying:
AI will replace the radiologist,
that will not replace the radiologist,
who's better.
It's really not about being better.
It's about being everywhere, 24/7,
being diligent, never taking a break,
which computers can do and humans can't.
Not to mention the cost.
So, the AI is always there in the cloud.
Every single scan goes to the cloud.
We're at about, I think,
45,000 scans a month now.
Going to the cloud, being interpreted,
about one out of ten is a stroke.
The AI identifies the stroke,
sends an alert,
the physician gets alert.
The physician, by the way,
is more often than not
in a different hospital
or at home or driving or whatnot,
they get the alert,
they have a mobile platform,
they can do the scans,
they can communicate with the team.
And this really changes
the flow of health care
from this sequential
one step after the other
very slow process.
Something, everybody gets the alert.
Everybody sinks in on the mobile platform,
makes a decision, go go go,
and treat the patient much much faster.
So, just to paint me the picture again.
Where is the scan taking place?
So let's say I'm the one
who is experiencing the health condition,
where am I physically located
while the scan is taking place?
And why am I so disconnected
from the whole health care system
that you're talking about?
Yeah. So, if you're unfortunate enough
to have a stroke
or to be suspected of a stroke,
you will be taken to hospital, to an ER,
and you will be scanned.
Now, during 60 and 70% of the time,
the facility that you're being scanned at
does not have the full capability
to treat you as a stroke patient.
You will need to be triaged
and transferred to another facility.
It's called the Comprehensive Strokes Center.
And I mean, immediately,
if you've been in the hospital once,
you know how inefficient this can be.
Immediately you see there's chain
of hand off that needs to happen.
And remember, also,
even in the smaller hospital,
it's less experienced,
they don't see as many strokes
or they're not as practiced with it.
And this is all due to human error,
due to overload, due to a tired physician
or just due to random stuff
like someone calling someone else
while they're already on the phone
with a third party.
Those delays introduced
and those drops in this process.
So, we completely eliminate this.
And actually, if you're okay with this,
I just want to share something
from literally from earlier today.
Yeah. Of course.
I can send this afterwards.
There's the post in LinkedIn
from Piedmont.
We just went live at Piedmont.
It was exciting day for us at Piedmont.
We have officially launched
with Viz.ai cross our health system.
Our first case came through
and LVO, LVO is the type of stroke,
was received even before the images
made it to the system.
Physician notes that Viz.ai saves
at least 15 minutes on this case.
15 minutes?
15 minutes is 60 days
of disability free life
and saves 150 days of potential
loss of functional independence.
This is from today.
This is like I shed a tear
when I read that.
David, I'm getting emotional here
listening to you say that.
So, you're reading this post,
and I'm literally tearing up
as I'm hearing this,
because this is probably something
that I'm the most passionate about,
using technology to literally save lives.
A lot of entrepreneurs go
and build products that are trying
to make the world a better place
or have a positive impact.
You're literally saving people's lives.
And you're not just saving them
from life and death,
you're also saving their well-being.
It's not just about whether they survive,
but it's about their quality of life
moving forward,
which I think is completely inspiring.
Talk to me a little bit
about your personal journey
going into this.
So, you're teaching assistant
at Tel Aviv University,
you work on algorithms at VMware,
you're a postdoc at Stanford.
How do you go into this realm
of artificial intelligence
and transition into co-founding
this amazing company?
Yeah. So, it's a good question.
And my background
has been a bit random.
Throughout my adult life,
have been gravitating towards
what's interesting and fun
and challenging.
And as you mentioned,
I worked and I developed algorithms.
In the tech industry,
I did some cool stuff in my undergrad,
masters and PhD.
And I came to Stanford for a postdoc
to focus on statistical learning
and genetics and genomics
and solve the world's problems.
And I guess, two main things happened:
one of them is, I guess,
everything depends on luck.
But I came to Stanford exactly when
for the first time
Convolutional Neural Networks class
was taught at Stanford.
And I was like completely randomly,
I stumbled upon it and I said,
"Well, let's go and listen
what is this stuff
that keeps coming up recently."
"Everybody saying this is a big deal."
And I go there, one or two lectures.
And it's obvious that
this is a game changer.
It's obvious that
something really really big
is happening here.
It's not another method,
another algorithm.
It's really about something
that's going to change a lot of things.
Do you remember who was
teaching the class back then?
Yeah. It was Andrej Karpathy,
famous CS231n
to like everybody whose done it.
CS231n, it's the notorious class
of Convolutional Neural Networks.
Yes. So, I mean, that was the first time
it was done at Stanford
and it was absolutely mind blowing.
Wow.
I mean, immediately I said,
"Okay. Let's see how we can apply that
in research, in genetics and genomics."
And start dabbling with medical imaging,
started playing with all sorts of stuff.
Completely unrelated to that,
I actually, the story I told you about
the patient being scanned and so on,
I actually experienced it.
I was admitted about five years ago
to Stanford Hospital
with a suspected stroke.
Really.
Yeah. So, actually,
it ended up not being a stroke.
And that's a different
neurological thing
that's completely reversible.
And I'm fine and healthy.
So, don't worry,
but like everything I tell you
about the delays, about the disconnect,
I literally experience those
being like unable to speak;
paralyzed in half of my body;
on a bed at Stanford
looking out and saying,
"What the hell is going on?"
"Why are things taking so long?"
And it is one of the best hospitals
in the world.
Exactly. it was like Monday morning,
you wouldn't feel like
Christmas Eve or something.
It was absolutely,
absolutely mind blowing.
So, half of the brain
is super freaked out that I'm going to be
disabled to rest of my life.
And half of the brain is like,
"What the fuck is going on?"
I'm sorry.
I don't know how to say that.
You can delete it.
No no no. This is 100% okay.
And I was fortunate
to meet my co-founder, Chris Mansi.
I was introduced actually
following this incident
by a mutual friend.
Chris is a neurosurgeon by training.
And he was at the business school
at Stanford and we actually met
at a friend's, sitting in his backyard
on the bonfire and I told him my story.
And he says to me,
"Dude, you're lucky you're alive."
"Everything is fine."
"I lost dozens of patients
on my operating table
over stupid stuff like someone
not picking up the phone
at the right time."
"And I actually came to Stanford
to fix this."
And like, we started talking,
"How would you fix this?"
If everything was automatic,
if computers were there instead of humans,
things would have been much better.
And I remember,
we actually Googled on his phone
some images and I look and said,
"I think with deep learning
we can probably automate this."
Unbelievable.
When was this? How long ago was this?
This was beginning of 2016.
Wow. So, we're talking about
four years ago.
And fast forward, and you're running
over a hundred person company
and you're saving lives.
So, talk to me a little bit
about what's happening today.
So, you're saying
you have 45,000 scans a month.
10% of those are our stroke cases.
Which means that in the current state,
you're literally helping save the lives
of 4,500 people,
either saving them from life and death
or saving their well-being
for hundreds of days, right?
Yeah. Yeah. So, I mean, now we've seen
very rapid adaption in the US.
We're live in over 500 hospital,
seeing a lot of patients.
Accumulating evidence
that implementation of this software
reduces the time,
improves patient outcomes,
reduces length of stay in the hospital
and all that coming from
different hospital systems across the US.
So, it's fairly robust.
Yeah, it's really exciting.
We're launching new products.
We're expanding beyond stroke.
We have a brain bleed product.
We have a few others that are
coming down the pipeline.
Yeah. It's actually been a lot of fun.
So, David, I have to ask company culture.
Because it's something
that's fascinating for me
as a young entrepreneur myself
and thinking about leadership
and what it means
to really motivate people,
and I'm seeing my class at Stanford
and my friends from 8200,
it's all about mission driven companies.
We want to join companies
that are mission driven,
that have a purpose that we feel
a part of a community.
I'm assuming this,
but if you're looking
at the hundred plus people
that are working at Viz.ai,
is there a shared goal here?
Do people understand the magnitude
of what you're achieving here?
Well, I think the answer is yes.
We put a lot of effort into it
and it's super important.
Furthermore, we have a core values
and the number one value
and by far the most important
is patient first.
And it's really about the patients.
Even recognizing that
it's about the patients,
not even about the users
or what is paying for the product.
We have different backgrounds
in the company.
People coming from health care,
which is a lot of the
commercial/ customer phasing,
they get it immediately.
We have a customer success team,
many of them are stroke nurses
and stroke coordinators jumped ship
because they understand that
this is the way to really transform.
In Israel, we have an engineering team
and we're slightly removed
from what's going on.
So, we do a lot.
We have all hands,
we have what we call
the magic moment section
where we share one or two stories
like the one I shared with you earlier.
We have our brain time fashion,
we call it, it's a 30 minute every week
where we just review interesting cases,
what happened;
did they use the app;
did they use it properly;
did something strange happened.
So, yes, we really try to connect
even every single person in the company
to the fact, I mean,
this is what differentiates from others
this Viz as place of work.
You can go work in other places,
some may even pay you more money,
but I strongly believe
it's one of those places where you can see
a very direct line from your work
to numbers of lives saved.
Unbelievable.
So, talk to me a little bit
about this intersection
of artificial intelligence
and health care and medicine in general.
Where is this headed?
Because this is something that
I guess, 10, 15 years ago,
there wasn't too much innovation
going on with, especially using
these technologies
and completely transforming the way
that health care is processed.
And just like
the amazing things that you're doing,
there's other companies
like Zebra Medical Vision
that are doing phenomenal things
and other companies around the world.
What is the trend?
And how can people that are perhaps,
pursuing a PhD in artificial intelligence
or that are mathematicians,
how can they find this smooth integration
in implementing these algorithms
into actual sustainable products
that can actually improve people's lives?
I guess that's a million dollar question.
And I think there's few ways to attack.
First of all, in terms of the trends,
yes, for a very long time,
not a lot has happened.
And I think most of the reason is that
people focused on trying to beat humans
at their own game by creating better.
There was a lot of focusing on ecology,
for example, in breast mammography,
trying to be better than a human
in a very hard task.
What we did at Viz, which was the first
and it was a new regulation
created by the FDA for us,
was not to compete with humans
in their own game, but say,
where does the computer
have an advantage
where time is of the essence.
All right.
So actually, algorithms
are not more accurate than humans.
Humans like the expert reading
this head scan, they don't miss a stroke.
It's not about accuracy.
It's about getting them in front
of the right patient at the right time.
And there you can show
very very substantial clinical benefit.
We convinced the FDA
they created a new regulation
called Computer Aided Triage for this.
And now, I just actually,
recently we did a survey about 30 devices
in this category using us as a predicate,
and this has become the number one way
for AI companies to have
a foot in the door
in the health care system.
So, what is the lesson?
I don't think the lesson is
you should go do triage.
I think the main thing is that
you have to sort of forget about AI,
and we have AI know a name here,
but let's forget about the AI for a second
and you have to really find a problem
that needs fixing.
A pain point
that's so painful to patients,
to physicians, and also
to the financial people of the hospital,
because stroke is financially
a very big deal.
It's actually the number one
health care expense in the US.
Wow.
And then you say,
"What do I need to fix it?"
And AI may be part of the solution.
And by the way, when I think of Viz,
when we ask our customers,
"What is the biggest feature of Viz
that you like the most?"
AI doesn't always come up first.
It's part of the whole solution.
The solution is a technology,
a mobile viewer,
skill chat they can use, it's AI.
It's also a customer success representative
that really understands stroke
and works with them
to improve their stroke workflow
and how they leverage
what Viz has to offer to improve
their own workloads on.
So, it's really holistic.
So, what I'm trying to say is
if you're an AI practitioner
and you have a hammer
and you're now looking for a nail,
everything looks like a nail.
Don't do that.
First, find the problem.
Convince yourself
that there's a clinical case,
a business case,
and then if AI can help you, wonderful.
100%. And it's inspiring
because what I'm gathering from this,
and you're saying it's not the AI
that is Viz.
It's Viz and AI is a component.
It's a tail of Viz.
And you're providing
this holistic experience
that is trying to capture
a lot of the misalignment
within the industry
or within the process
of a potential stroke patient.
The AI is sort of the helper tool
to allow that to happen.
But it's all these other resources,
whether it's the customer success person
or the secure chat,
or understanding the problems
of that specific organization.
And I think that's a really big lesson
that I'm taking from this.
Because as a technology enthusiast myself,
I'm constantly reminding myself
that it's not just about the algorithm,
it's not just about the code.
It's about how do you actually
bring this to market
and make it something that's useful.
David, this was inspiring and insightful.
Thank you for taking the time to do this.
And I'm sure that it's
running over one hundred person company
and doing the things that you're doing,
I'm definitely very very honored
that you're willing to do this.
But before we leave,
I have to ask for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Okay. So, the first one,
I think it's two words,
but it's [--]
I would say, naive/ optimistic.
Like people make fun of me all the time.
I always think some things are like
would be really easy to do,
and they always turn out to be harder.
But you have to believe
that you can do it
and that it's possible,
so take the first step.
And I think the second one would be
something big for me right now,
it's being a father.
I'm a father of three.
And we have a six month baby
that was born just before
the lockdown here.
Wow.
So, kids are probably a big thing,
but recently, even more than that.
And the third thing I would say,
I thought about
going with geek, nerd thing,
but I actually went with a statistician.
I'm a Holocaust statistician by training.
I do machine learning and stuff,
but my training is statistics.
And I consider myself a statistician
who apply statistics
to how he thinks about the world.
And that actually has been
extremely useful at the Viz journey
and in life in general.
So, yeah, I guess we'll go to those three.
David, thank you very much. Toda raba.
Keep helping save people's lives.
And I'll keep following the journey.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.